this guy's running a real estate office
and a consultant for me says pat
i have two guys in my office that are
trans i said okay and how do i handle it
i said what do you mean how do you
handle it i'm in the state of california
how do i handle it
i said what's your point he says they're
making other people feel uncomfortable
and i have a couple people who quit who
are my top producers and i'm worried if
i say something
they could go and say something to the
city and then i may get and then i'm
dealing with hr how do i handle this
right okay so how do you handle that
situation how does an operator handle
that situation does the operator go and
say hey man listen this is too
uncomfortable for us you're making
people around you uncomfortable you got
to leave but what are they doing that's
making them uncomfortable just being
there is uncomfortable
just being there is uncomfortable
because people are coming we live by why
are you why do you have clothes on what
do i have clothes on why does he have a
nice why do we why because we live by
what first impression right i walk into
an office and my first impression is oh
okay huh
interesting what's going on so
people to now you may say pat what's the
big deal with that it doesn't matter
what's a big deal or not we judge but
here's the point
many people in america today are walking
on eggshells
people are afraid to say what they
really feel because they may get in
trouble for that and people are getting
sick of that i agree they're getting the
fact that yesterday johnny depp's story
whether it's a true story or not disney
may offer the guy 301 million dollars to
get him to play uh what do you call it
uh
jack sparrow pirates of the caribbean if
they give this guy 301 million dollars
guess what if he wins guess who won
man's men won men won
this whole thing of trying to pansify
all men to become softer and sissies i
like the fact that johnny depp stood up
not if he didn't stand up
for the rest of us our careers we would
have thought maybe he was a
dirt back on what he did to amber hurt
and we're saying ah you know what what
up the article on valuetainment yeah we
wrote a great article on that 301
million dollars i hope it's a true story
i don't know if it is or not can i maybe
and then this might be the perfect segue
to roger stone i don't know if men won i
think maybe
um
being innocent until proven guilty one i
think you know
anti-cancer culture one i think
stop judging uh
pre-judging
anything before you the facts come out
one
um
everyone basically you know did you see
that what disney we could go on
valuetainment disney basically gave an
apology like we basically came down on
one down on bended knee and said
our bat mia culpa over here because they
much like the kanto culture warriors out
there
were quick to dismiss him and now you
know the reason they're offering him 301
million
it's because he said i would never play
this again even if they paid me 300
million well you know
here's a little 301 million there for
you buddy um but
i mean maybe you want to weigh in on
what it feels like to do that i think i
agree with your analysis uh uh you know
first of all it was epically
entertaining so you had to every night
go see what was the latest in the trip
yeah um but i think truth won i think he
he acquitted himself well by presenting
his side of the case and doing it
compellingly uh there was a i think a
preconceived judgment for her in the
beginning what a horrible toxic male he
was what an abusive individual he was
uh i was glad to see the way it came out
it did but roger you should believe all
women period yeah why don't you but yeah
right but but what you so you're being
sarcastic no well i'm i'm not being
sarcastic but you're being sarcastic and
you're saying this has nothing to do
with men
but there's more it's more than men
i said yesterday i'm glad we're
transitioning away from guilty until
proven innocent instead of innocent
until proven guilty i get that but the
fact that you threw that sarcastic
comment at the end
means men get destroyed when it comes
down to this topic and it's good to see
men like him stand up if you screwed up
you deserve to you know whatever you're
getting if you didn't stand up boom
we're seeing progress so america is
simply getting sick of it the more and
more politics is getting involved
they're just getting sick of it saying
listen let me be able to give my opinion
without getting destroyed my career just
because i disagree with you so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]